from Disney's bitter ex-boyfriend comes
the finale of the saga so bad this
ridiculous overacted disappointing mass
is known as the good one
Star Wars Revenge of the Sith return to
a time long ago when there was still
hope that the prequels could stick the
landing with a film that starts out semi
promising this is where the fun begins
then falls flat on its stupid face watch
Star Wars finish its turn to the dark
side as everything you bro - hey returns
midi-chlorians younglings came to cool
and cringe as Anakin Skywalker completes
his journey from annoying kid to
obnoxious teenager to insufferable Jedi
Knight in a performance so robotic his
body finally catches up to his acting
although to be fair no one can make this
drag sound natural love won't save you
Padme only my new powers can do that
Natalie Portman is back and she's just
kind of there weep as this once proud
Queen senator and warrior spends the
whole movie barefoot and pregnant and I
want to have our baby back home on Naboo
I can go early and fix up the baby's
here and finally witness what the whole
trilogy has been building - Anakin
Skywalker becoming Darth Vader watch the
greatest movie villain of all time turn
evil because he's passed up for a
promotion we do not grant you the rank
of Master has a bad dream about his
secret wife commits Jedi sighed when an
old man gives him a super vague promise
about cheating death then gets burnt to
a crisp because his teacher is standing
on a hill
I have the high ground so Darth Vader is
a whiny dumb easy to manipulate lap dog
who got his suit because he couldn't
quite jump high enough mystery solved
thanks for clearing that up George
experienced the best our Wars prequel by
default simply because something
occasionally happens even if that's
something is a lizard chasing a robot on
a unicycle
but don't worry fans of sitting and
talking because every time things start
to get interesting George Lucas gives us
some of the Sidious Tokio scenes in the
trilogy featuring council meetings
therapy sessions close to you yes
commutes with all due respect master is
he not the chosen one weird bubble shows
I don't think Anakin and just staring
out of the window
all slowly building up to the most
obvious reveal of all time that the evil
Sith Lord is the sinister old guy who
talks exactly like the evil Sith Lord Oh
gasp not the guy who does four evil head
turns in one conversation on the Jedi
don't create life from dying not from a
Jedi
what a twist after two pointless wheel
spinning movies watch a finale where
Anakin goes from peaceful Jedi to child
murdering maniac in less than ten
minutes it's not the Jedi way you must
live there are too many of them
what are we going to do followed by 20
minutes of George Lucas jamming everyone
into their new hope starting positions
even if it ruins the franchise
continuity like how did Leia remember
her mom's face she was very beautiful
why didn't obi-wan remember Leia that
boy is our last photo there is enough
derp how did Owen and Beru age forty
years in 20 years why does all the
galaxy's technology look like it got
worse and how can we ever take Darth
Vader seriously again after we've seen
this
know is right starring the falling proof
that more does not equal better one
ham-handed cameo goodbye Chewbacca to
disposable CGI armies two cyborgs with
breathing problems for lightsabers at
the same time for unnecessary CGI flippy
jabs a severed limbs about 17 things
r2d2 couldn't do in the original and
thousands of highly trained Jedi Knights
going down like total pogs seriously you
can get through droids and clones like
tissue paper and that's how you go out
that's that's pathetic man star wars
episode 111 the four so weekends if you
think the movie was bad wait until you
see what they cut out it's broken can
you understand what he's saying
I'm pretty sure that beep is down oh yes
yes yes you're right beep is up
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers hey screen junkies can't get
enough of the prequels then be sure to
check out michael barratt e and belated
media's what-if episode 3 were good the
epic conclusion to their prequel trilogy
click the link in the box above or the
younglings get it may the force be with
you Anakin you're breaking my heart you
were the chosen one you were supposed to
destroy the Sith not join them from my
point of view the Jedi are evil hold me
like you did on the lake on Naboo power
unlimited power you underestimate my
power oMG so excited for Star Wars